regarding the three things that you
mentioned earlier about creating empathy
for a character you talked about
admiration you also talked about feeling
sorry for someone or or seeing them in a
situation where you could kind of relate
to feeling sorry for yourself or
whatever right yeah what if the
admiration part is too heavy because we
don't want a character that's gonna be
too perfect and then they're like right
right the lesson is don't don't make
make sure you make your character human
let make sure it's realistic you know
nobody's perfect right so when you have
a character who's completely perfect
that we don't really buy it but these
techniques are used for characters who
are also quote like villains for example
I was used to Sopranos Dexter Breaking
Bad as a character who's technically not
likable or they do something that carve
immoral and yet we connect with them we
care about them so that's how it's done
so you can use this on any any character
the trick of it I mean the the thing
about how you do it specifically is
really up to the writer I mean I like to
use to see these techniques as tools so
you have these tools and then it's but
it's your job to apply them well you
know when you couldn't apply them and
and put all of them in one scene it's
gonna look ridiculous so it's almost
like a painter and you have your your
brushes and your colors a few little
touches here and touches there and then
the effect is is artistic but it's up to
the artist you know and you could do it
badly you could do it good you could do
it balance that's up to you right so
it's taking Breaking Bad you have Walter
White where toward the beginning he's at
the car wash the beginning is a master
class right and another one that I like
to use is as good as good as it gets
Oh Melvin Udall I use that amount you
see her classes all the time because
that's that's a character that was
purposely created to create and they'll
create the worst character ever made you
know the most disliked character New
York who falls in love with the most
liked you know sweetest waitress that
was kind of a romantic comedy that vain
and I thought when you when you see the
the you know the first 10 15 pages of as
good as it gets is a master class in a
cuisine you know the I mean he's doing
things that are like horrific you know
they always say do not harm an animal
and he's there throwing the dog down the
chute
uh-uh he insults people he's
misogynistic he's racist you know all
whatever but as soon as he walks into
that door into his to his apartment and
you get to see that he is that he's
compulsive disorder they something is
wrong with him right there that's the
first hit of feeling kind of sorry for
him you know so it could be totally bad
when you find out they're sick you you
it's it's part of us to feel kind of
story and kind of connect and there's a
whole thing with a dog despite the fact
that he threw the dog down the chute the
dog likes him yeah so that's another
thing and he takes care of it that's
another thing so gradually we get to
really like him and connect despite his
flaws have you ever given notes to
someone to say can you make them less
perfect um
don't like they're too superhuman people
aren't gonna like them uh yeah it's
usually like I don't really kind of
focus on those specifically like traits
for me is the last thing you should
worry about like you know I know it's
like this is a my character development
and how to create characters and talk
about okay make sure you give him
positive traits negative trades but
that's just one aspect of and that's the
easiest thing to do for me it's more
about how what happens to your character
and those things I've talked about like
the pity humanity and admiration and
kind of balance the three and then
everything else you can show in that
scene or in future scenes but yeah that
doesn't come too often yeah what
somebody's really too perfect and
you